la de hoy fue la primera reunión
conjunta en la historia entre un alto
representante de la diplomacia europea y
18 cancilleres del bloque birregional
centroamérica y el caribe el encuentro
tuvo lugar en ciudad de panamá donde
claramente se vio cómo se estrecharon
las relaciones entre los países de esta
región del mundo y el bloque europeo
cuyo representante josep borrel destacó
la necesidad de apoyarlos de apoyar a
sus socios sobre todo en el marco de la
guerra de ucrania y ante las
consecuencias económicas que ya está
dejando la que él denominó la guerra de
rusia cuando se reunió con los ministros
de relaciones exteriores del caribe
subrayó los profundos lazos históricos
económicos y culturales que los unen con
europa porque recordemos que estas islas
alguna vez fueron colonias de ingleses
neerlandeses franceses españoles y al
escuchar las vulnerabilidades económicas
por las cuales están atravesando recordó
el compromiso de 800 millones de euros
de inversión en las islas del caribe en
el período 2021 y 2027 en el caso
centroamericano una región donde se
señala que existen gobiernos
autoritarios y corruptos borrell apuntó
la necesidad de que haya estado de
derecho institucionalidad democrática y
derechos humanos para un posible
progreso económico y también desde
panamá josep borrell anunció nuevas
sanciones contra bancos rusos para
expulsarlos prontamente el sistema
internacional swift y así hacerle
hincapié a las importaciones de petróleo
de rusia